اني يعقوب من بيتونيا فلسطين العزاء
مستمر في الاقصى الى السادسه
ذلك
نذكر باستمرار عزاء الدكتور غازي صالح
بني ملحم
من اربد الاردن
العزاء مستمر الليله من السبعه للعشره في
قاعه ترمس عيا العنوان على الشاشات
غفر الله لنا ولهما ولموت المسلمين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد يقول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا
لا يسخر قوم من قوم عسى ان يكونوا خيرا
منهم
ولا نساء من نساء عسى ان يكن خيرا منهن
ولا تلمزوا انفسكم ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
بئس الاسم الفسوق بعد الايمان
ومن لم يتب فاولئك هم الظالمون
يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من
الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
ايحب احدكم ان ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا
فكرهتموه
واتقوا الله ان الله تواب رحيم
قول الله سبحانه وتعالى بئس الاسم الفسوق
بعد الايمان ذكرنا ان لفظه الفسوق
بدل
اعراب يعني
موقع هذه الكلمه من الجمله الفسوق بدل من
الاسم
كيف نفهم البدل
يعني
نبدل بينه وبين المبدل منه فيكون التقدير
بئس الاسم بعد الايمان بئس الفسوق بعد
الايمان
وهذا
يفيدنا فوائد
وذلك ان فيه اختصارا شديدا في الكلام
ان هذا التصرف وسوق
وهذا الفسوق بئس ما يكون
الفسوق بعد الايمان
وكذلك
هذه
البنيه للجمله تفيدنا
ان
هذه الاسامي
والالقاب
الرديئه التي يتنابز بها الناس
فيما بينهم
فانها لا تليق بالمؤمن
المؤمن ارفع درجه
من ذلك لا يمكن
لمن كان يعظم المؤمنين
ان يرضى باطلاق امثال هذه الالقاب على احد
من اخواني او احدى اخواته من ذوي الايمان
قال تعالى ومن لم يتب فاولئك هم الظالمون
وهذا فيه دليل ايضا استدل به المفسرون على
ان ما سبق
من امور من هي
هذه الاشياء التي ذكرها الله ونها عنها
السخريه
وكذلك
اللمس
وكذلك التنابز بالالقاب هذه
من اجل ان تغتفر لابد ان يتوب المرء منها
وهذا دليل
من ضمن الادله على ان هذه من كبائر الذنوب
على تعريف كثير من العلماء
بعض العلماء
والخلاف بين العلماء في تعريف الكبيره
معروفه
معروف وهي مساله مهمه والله عز وجل
علق على هذا التعريف احيانا فقال ان
تجتنبوا كبائر ما تنهون عنه
نكفر عنكم
فما هي هذه الكبائر التي نهينا عنها بعض
العلماء
ابتداء من عصر الصحابه
يعلى الكبير
ما جاءت مذكوره في هذا السياق يعني اي
حديث فيه ذكر الكبيره
مثل قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان من
اكبر الكبائر ان يلعن الرجل والديه مثلا
هذا حديث
فذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هنا
ان هذه
المعصيه كبيره
وهلم جره
واجتنبوا السبع الموبقات
الموبقات يعني المهلكات هذه من صفات
الكبائر كبائر الذنوب فبعض العلماء عدى
الكبائر
على هذا
وبعضهم
جعل الكبائر
في رقم محدود كما جاء عن بعض الصحابه ابن
عمر وابن عباس
ان الكبائر مثلا سبعه او ان الكبائر مثلا
تسعه او عشره وما شابه ذلك
وهذا لا شك ان هذه التي تكون معدوده وفي
سياق واحد لا شك انها تكون من اكبر
الكبائر لكن
هذا
فيه نوع نقص لان ثم ذنوب اخرى
لا
يصدق ان تكون من الصغائر لانه اذا كلنا
احنا كبيره ايش ضد الكبيره الصغيره هذا
اختيارنا الثاني فاذا جعلنا الكبائر فقط
سبعه او فقط تسعه اصبح الان عنا اشياء
كثيره بدنا نسميها صغائر وهذا لا يليق بها
ماشي مثل الغيبه والنميمه
والامور التي قد تكون فظيعه لكنها ليست
مذكوره في هذا السياق
عرف بعضه العلماء الكبيره بالصفه
يعني ما اعطوا الكبيره
هذه التسميه مثلا او رقما معينا وانما
قالوا الكبيره
كل ذنب له الصفات التاليه
وهذا جاء عن عبد الله بن عباس
رضي الله عنه وعن ابي وذلك انه قال رضي
الله عنهما ان الكبير
ما اختتم
باللعن
او النار
او العقاب
يعني العقاب الدنيا الحد
ان هذه هي الكبيره
وهذا التعريف هو الذي كاد ان يستقر عليه
راي العلماء
خاصه بعد
القرن السابع والثامن من الهجره فان
الفقهاء كادوا
يجمعون على مثل هذا التعريف التعريف
للكبيره
بعد التعريف الكبير
كل ما له
عقاب مخصوص
يعني ذكر له عقاب مخصوص
هذا العقاب المخصوص
اما ان يتوعد بنوع من العذاب او يتوعد
باسم يقال له فاسق او يقال له
فاجر او يقال له كي توكيت او هذا الفعل له
اسم خاص هو كفر او هو فسق مثلا
او
ما كان له عقاب خاص في الدنيا
مثل الحد
مثل الرجم او الجلد او ما شابه ذلك
فهذا هو
تعريف الكبير الذي
اشتهر بين العلماء
وهو الذي
ينضبط تحته احكام كثيره فاذا نظرنا الى
الكبيره من هذه الناحيه وجدنا ان الكبائر
ماذا كثيره جدا من الكبائر
ما هي مذكوره في القران ومن الكبائر ما هي
مذكوره في السنه
ولكن الكبيره كل ما له عقاب خاص خصص بعقاب
معين
توعد به فاعله فان هذه تسمى عند العلماء
بالكبير وضدها ايش الصغيره وثم كبائر هي
اكبر الكبائر لان الكبائر ليست على على حد
سواء وليست على مستوى واحد كما ان الصغائر
ليست على مستوى واحد
ومن الخطا ان يظن الظن ان الكبيره ضد
الصغيره اذا هي على نفس المستوى وهذا خطا
لان الكبائر درجات او نقول الكبائر دركت
كما ان الصغائر تركت
واذا فهمنا هذا
فهمنا مثل قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلوات الخمس
ورمضان الى رمضان
والجمعه الى الجمعه كفاره لما بينهن اذا
اجت من اذا اجتنبت الكبائر طيب هاي السؤال
السؤال طيب انا صمت رمضان مثلا
وفي الحديث من قام رمضان ايمانا واحتسابا
غفر له طيب انا صمت رمضان وقمت رمضان
طيب ومن قام ليله القدر ايمانا واحتسابا
غفر له ما تقدم من ذنبه ماشي وفقني الله
فكنت ليله القدر وبعدين برضو الصلوات
الخمس صليتها وبرضو الجمعه صليت كل جمعه
ماذا يكون من كفاره يعني لماذا جعل الله
سبحانه وتعالى هذه الاشياء التي
تكفر بها الصغائر متتابعه هكذا
يعني في نفس الشهر قد يجتمع اربعه او خمس
من مكفرات الذنوب لماذا يحتاج اليها
الانسان لان الصغائر ليست على نفس المستوى
اما صغائر هي اكبر
من بعض الصغائر الاخرى فياتي
اجر هذه العباده فيكفر الله
جزءا وقسطا من هذه الصغائر لكن هذه
العباده لم تقوى على ان
لاسباب معلومه عند الله سبحانه وتعالى وفي
عدله وفي قوه العمل
وشده الاحسان في العمل مثلا فهذا يؤثر في
اجر العمل وقبول العمل وتاثير العمل في
تكفير هذه الذنوب
على كل حال الصغائر ليست على مستوى واحد
وياتي
وياتي اجر عباده يكفر الله
به كثيرا لكن
بقي شيء
فاذا تتابعت للخيرات وتتابع
وتتابعت اجور
الاجور الطاعات فانه
حري بالشخص ان يخرج من هذا الشهر او هذه
الفتره او هذا الموسم وهو
مغفور له هذه الصغائر واما الكبائر من
الذنوب فانها تحتاج الى توبه لا يمكن ان
تغتفر كبيره من كبائر الذنوب
وصاحبها مصر عليها لابد ان يتوب الى الله
من هذا ينزع ويتوب
والا
فهذه الكبيره تبقى
فقوله سبحانه وتعالى ومن لم يتب فاولئك هم
الظالمون سماهم ظالمين لانهم امتنعوا عن
التوبه وهذه الامور
الظاهر انها تقع من جميع الناس في الغالب
فالجميع
له حظ من هذه الذنوب في حياته فيبقى
من لم يتب بعد العلم من لم ينزع عن هذا
بعد ان علم بعد ان علمه الله ان هذه من
امور الجاهليه وهذه من امور الاسلام ولا
تليق للمؤمنين وبئس الاسم الفسوح بعد
الايمان ومن لم يتوب فاولئك هم الظالمون
واذا نظرنا الى
الى هذه التسميه
ومن لم يتب من هنا
اسم موصول
وهو من صيغ العموم
جميع الناس
وقع منهم التوبه ومطلوب منهم التوبه
ومامرون بالتوبه
ومن لم يتب من جميع الناس
فاولئك هم الظالمون
وهذا مثل قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كل ابن ادم خطاء
وخير الخطائين التوابون
يعني الفرق بين
الخير
ودون الخير
التوبه فهنا قوله تعالى ومن لم يتب فاولئك
هم الظالمون استحقوا هذه التسميه ان
يكونوا ظالمين واما من تاب واناب واستغفر
ورجع وامر بالمعروف ونهى عن المنكر واعتصم
بالله واخلص دينه لله
فاولئك مع الصالحين
الله عز وجل يقول ما يفعل الله بعذابكم
شكرتم وامنتم
هذا شيء لا يفيد الله سبحانه وتعالى وانما
نحن الذين
نستفيد من
العقاب نعم نحن نستفيد من العقاب والاخرون
يستفيدون من العقاب عقاب الظالمين منا
والا فان الله تعالى لا تضره معصيتنا ولا
تنفعه
حسناتنا فلذلك يقول تعالى ما يفعل الله
بعذابكم ان شكرتم وامنتم هذا هو المطلوب
منكم الشكر والايمان فاذا شكرتم وامنتم
فان العذاب لا
يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا
من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
وهذا النداء الخامس
بهذه الصيغه في الصوره يا ايها الذين
امنوا
قررها الله سبحانه وتعالى خمس مرات
وتحت كل نداء
وكل نداء من هذه النداءات التي جاءت في
هذه السوره فانها بمنزله ايش باب بمنزله
الباب من الكتاب
لان تحت كل نداء
نوع من انواع الاداب
وقد ذكرنا عند ابتداء السوره ان هذه
الصوره
يعني صميم الصوره في
الاداب
والخلق الذي
ينبغي ان يتخلق به المؤمن لكن هذه الاداب
تختلف تختلف
الاداب التي تنبغي
في التعامل مع الله ورسوله او مع رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم او مع الفساق او
مع المؤمنين او مع
فهذه اداب مختلفه وكل نداء من هذه
النداءات يا ايها الذين امنوا فان له
ارتباط
بصلب الصوره كما ان ابواب الكتاب
لها ارتباط بعنوان الكتاب ولكن كل باب له
له معنى وله
قسط من هذه الاداب فقوله سبحانه وتعالى يا
ايها الذين امنوا لا تقدموا بين يدي الله
ورسوله
هذا كان في ماذا في التادب مع الله سبحانه
وتعالى لا تقدموا بين يدي الله ورسوله
يعني في الحكم
ياتي احدنا الى شيء لا يعلم الحكم فيه ثم
يتقدم
حكم الله سبحانه وتعالى برايه قل انا رايه
هيك رايي كذا او يقدم على فعل الشيء
دون اذن من الله
ودنا ان يعلم الحكم عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى وذكر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
هنا
لانه
مبلغ عن الله طيب يا ايها الذين امنوا لا
ترفعوا اصواتكم فوق صوت النبي هذا ادب مع
من مع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سواء ادب
حسي معه في حياته
او ادب معنوي يكون بعد وفاته صلى الله
عليه وسلم ثم ننتقل الى يا ايها الذين
امنوا ان جاءكم فاسق بنبا فتبين وهذا ادب
معنى مع
الفساق من المؤمنين يعني المرتكب للكبيره
او المرتكب للذنوب الذي
لم يكمل ايمانه الظاهر
ثم جاء يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر قوم
من قوم فهذا من الاداب مع مع الذي هو مؤمن
لكنه غريب كيف يعني غريب يعني مؤمن من بلد
اخرى من عائله اخرى من منطقه اخرى من دوله
ثانيه
صح والعاده بين الناس بانهم يسخروا من بعض
ويتجنبوا بعض لانهم
يعني هذا الشخص مش من بلدي وعاداته تختلف
فالله عز وجل يقول لا يسخر قوم من قوم عسى
ان يكونوا خيرا منهم حتى لو كنت قرشا عشان
يكون خيرا منهم ولذلك جاء في صيغه القوم
ولم يقل احد من احد
ثم ياتي النداء الخامس وهو قوله يا ايها
الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن
فهذا الان
وادب لكن ادب مع من مع المؤمن القريب
الذي يسكن في نفس المنطقه يكون في نفس
الجو
يكون من
نفس القوم من بلدك الان كيف
يتصرفون لا
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
هذا يقع في المجتمع
كثيرا وهذه ادب
كلها من الجاهليه
كلها من الجاهليه هذه الاخلاق
التي نهى الله سبحانه وتعالى عنها كلها من
الجاهليه التفاخر بالانساب وغيبه المؤمن
وانتهاك عرض الاخر
يعني تصديق الفساق في الامور واصابه الناس
بغير ذنب
محقق هذه كلها من امور الجاهليه كان يعاني
من هذه الاخلاق الرديئه
المجتمع الجاهلي فجاء الاسلام
فنور الله سبحانه وتعالى
البصائر
والبصر
واصبحنا بنعمته اخوان بعد ان كنا على شفى
حفره من النار فانقذنا الله منها فلابد ان
تراعى هذه لانها بمنزله السياج التي
يحمي المجتمع المحافظ
بعضه بعض
والعرض امر مهم جدا يعني نحن نولي
ايرا من الاهتمام للمال
وللحاسه للجسد هل يعني فلان اذا ما اعتدى
عليك في
مالك او ما اعتدى عليك في جسمك
وانما اعتدى على عرضك على سمعتك اعتدى على
عليك
معنويا
فان هذا مغتفر في كثير من المجتمع وهذا
خطا لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
ان
اموالكم
واعراضكم
ودماءكم عليكم حرام
كحرمتي يومكم هذا في شهركم هذا في بلدكم
هذا
هذا كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم جمع
الثلاثه
من المسلم فقال المسلم من سلم المسلمون من
لسانه ويده
وقيل من المؤمن قال من امنه الناس على
دمائهم واموالهم
عن المجاهد الذي يجاهد نفسه في ذات الله
من المهاجر من هاجر ما نهى الله عنه
الحديث عند الحاكم في المستدرك لاسناد
صحيح وحديث معروف ومعاني معروفه لدينا
على كل حال هذه الاخلاق يستهين بها كثير
من الناس والمجتمع المنهار الخاوي على
عروشه فان كثيرا من الاحيان نجد ان الظاهر
ظاهر بهيم ولكن اذا نظرنا الى هذه الامور
وجدنا ان هذا الجسد مريض فيه مرض
اسلامكن فيه مرض مرض
الاستحقاق يستحقر بعضه بعض يعني تصور انت
تصور لو جسد
لو جسد اصبح غير
مختلفا واصبح هذا الجسد هذه اليد
كانها دون هذه اليد
فالدماء ولهذا يذهب الى هذه اليد اكثر من
هذه
وبعض هذا الجسد مستحقر وبعض هذا الجسد
معظم وبعض هذا الجسد ياتيه
الدواء وياتيه
الطعام والتغذيه وهذا
هذا هذا الطرف من الجسد لا ياتيه الا دون
ذلك كيف يكون الانسان في هذه الحاله الجسد
هذا يموت
وحري به ان يهلك صاحبه
والمجتمع وكالجسد الواحد اذا اشتكى منه
عضو تداعى له سائر الجسد بالسهر والحمى
ليس المجتمع فقط الاغنياء الاغنيه مهمين
نعم
قدر الاغنياء ولهم منزلتهم في المجتمع لكن
ما بنعظمهم على الفقراء النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول
ان الفقراء انما
ننصر بالفقراء
ونرزق بالفقراء بفقرائنا هيك الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول
احنا ما
بنعظم
الغني على حساب الفقير هذا لا يكون
نفس الشيء انه الجسد يهلك بعضه من اجل ان
يبقي بعضه او يعظم بعضه هذا جسد حري به ان
يموت وان يهلك صاحبه
وعلى كل حال قوله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها
الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض
الظن اثم فيه التحفظ وهذا يدلنا على قاعد
مهمه في القضاء
والروايه فيها ضعيفه لكن المعنى اتفق عليه
العلماء وذلك اننا
ندرى
الشبهات
ندرء الحدود بالشبهات هكذا جاء في الحديث
ادراوه الحدود بالشبهات الحديث
سند ضعيف لكن العلماء كلهم اجمعوا على صحه
هذا المعنى وياتي هذا ان شاء الله غدا
باذن الله والله اعلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
على نبينا محمد